and look who is joining us
via peacock it's seton o'connor looks
where where are you
i'm right here outside paul brown
stadium i got my man kyle with me
getting ready to get pied okay
um how was yesterday before you get your
pie for losing the uh chiefs bengals ben
yesterday was good we uh we did about
650 miles so we didn't get to cincinnati
but we got to columbus we covered a lot
of ground um went through pittsburgh it
was cool what did you do in columbus
uh really just ate pizza and wings and
went to bed
okay that's it dude by the time we got
there we were like
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then uh so cincinnati you get your
pie
and then
going to nashville later today are you
going to get to memphis tonight
yeah the plan is to go through nashville
and get to memphis tonight and uh we got
some barbecue lined up there we got a
couple of cool things we're going to do
there too so uh it's going to be a fun
fun one okay so explain the bet
so the bet was kyle called in right big
bengals fan ahead wednesday
and kyle called in towards the end of
the show uh obviously bragging uh he
felt good about the bengals against the
chiefs
and he challenged us to a bet and it
kind of i wasn't gonna say anything but
then it dawned on me that like wait a
minute i think we're driving through
cincinnati so i could if i take this bet
one way or the other somebody's getting
a pie and that equals content so i was
like hell yeah dude i'll take the chiefs
all day all right uh i see that you have
plastic you're you're practicing uh safe
uh pie throwing and we are practicing
safe pie throwing because it also dawned
on me today that smelling like a
skyline chili pie oh
all the way to memphis
no idea
what so that's got the chili is that a
five-way a three-way what is that kyle
just a two-way chili and cheese chili
and cheese okay no noodle
all right uh
is
is the french kid holding the camera
i'm gonna give the french kid uh my
phone and then uh we'll get ready are
you ready for the pie yes yes we'll okay
great yeah we'll count it down here okay
hold on one second
seating uh outside oh man brown stadium
that's a lot of chili i didn't know it
was gonna be a skyline pie
all right uh so
yeah uh all right you ready
three
two
one
he's got a glob of cheese on his face
yeah i could use a towel though does
anybody have a towel that i could get oh
man oh
so so my brother
what the hell is my brother doing there
let me tell you something your brother
is probably the best producer out in the
field right now he pretty much set the
whole thing up
so my brother who lives outside of
cincinnati and mason he said uh hey if
seton needs something
then i'll i'll be there for him he's got
a he's
he's got a friend here i can always help
him so my my oldest brother
helping him he came here he brought he
got uh him and actually i don't know if
i should give your lovely wife some
credit here
yeah yeah yeah uh she got the poncho it
was like well you can't drive all the
way to memphis smelling like skylight
chilly so that's the moment it dawned on
me that was probably a really bad idea
it was when his wife was like you guys
you can't do that
all right uh let us know when you get
through nashville and uh my thanks to uh
my brother and his wife sue
thank you buddy buddy all right bye guys
that was great
yeah
and kyle too kyle who won the bend
outside the football stadium now he gets
in the sprinter van with the french kid
and heads to nashville
yeah my brother i talked to my brother
yesterday he goes you know seaton needs
help you know i'll be more than happy to
help him i go no i think he's good
next thing i know he's
coming up with the bit hey let's do a
skyline pie there
well done that's original